PROFESSOR: We are going to
recap some of the last results
we had on scattering and
then push them to the end
and complete our discussion
of this integral equation
and how we approximate
scattering with it.
It's a pretty powerful method
of thinking about scattering
and gives you a
direct solution, which
is in a sense more intuitive
perhaps than when you're
dealing with partial waves.
So let's see where
we were last time.
So we set up our solution
of the Schrodinger equation
in a funny way.
We had an incoming
wave plus a term that
still had an integral over
all of space of our Green's
function integrated
against a scaled version
of the potential.
Remember that v
was defined to be
equal to the potential up
to some constants, h bar
squared over m.
And we had this
integral equation
where one could show
that phi satisfies
the correct
Schrodinger equation.
Now this function G plus
was our Green function
that we also discussed.
And it was given by
the following formula.
It just depends on the magnitude
of this vector argument
of the Green's
function, so 1 over 4 pi
e to the ik, magnitude
of that divided
by magnitude of that vector.
So in most applications, we
look at the wave function.
This should be phi of r.
We look at the wave
function far away.
And if the potential
is localized,
this integral, since it
involves the potential,
can only be non-zero, have
non-zero contributions
to the integral on the region
where the potential exists.
So r prime, whenever
you're doing this integral,
must be small compared to r.
This we can draw here.
So assume we have a potential.
And you have an
observation point, r.
We'll call the unit vector
in this direction n.
This is the vector r.
And an integration point
is a point, r prime here.
And there is this
distance, this vector,
in between r minus r prime.
And finally, on this graph,
we could also have a direction
that we could call the
incident direction, perhaps
the z-direction.
And that's the direction
which your wave is incident.
This is the wave that
were represented here.
So we did a little approximation
of this Green's function
for the case where r
prime where you're looking
is much smaller than r.
In that case, the
distance, r minus r prime,
is approximately
equal to r minus--
so that's the
distance, the vectors.
When you don't put an
arrow, we mean the distance.
So this is r minus
n dot r prime.
To 0-th approximation, this
is the most important term.
To next approximation
comes this term
because that term is
suppressed with respect
to the original term by a
factor of r prime over r.
So if you factored, for
example, the r here,
you would say 1 minus
n r prime over r.
So you see that
this ratio enters
here, which says that the second
term is smaller by this factor.
We could even include
more terms here.
But those would not
be relevant unless k
is extremely high energy.
So when k is very large,
it would make a difference.
But it has to be
extremely large.
And in general,
this approximation
isn't enough for any k
for sufficiently far away.
So this is really good enough.
And the approximation is
done on the Green's function
at two levels.
You need to be mildly accurate
with respect to this quantity.
But you need to be more accurate
with respect to this phase
because the phase can
change rather fast depending
on the wavelength of the object.
So if you make an error in
the total distance of 1%,
that's not big deal.
But if you make an
error here, such that k
dot times this distance
is comparable to 1,
the phase could
be totally wrong.
So the phase is always
a more delicate thing.
And therefore, with
this approximation,
your G plus of r minus r prime
becomes minus 1 over 4 pi e
to the ikr over r.
So we replace this
term by just r.
And in this exponent,
the absolute value
is replaced by two terms.
The first one is e
to the ikr, is here.
The second one is e to
the minus ikn dot r prime.
We also have here
the incident vector.
You can write e to the ikz
as e to the ik incident
dotted with r if k incident
is a vector, k, times the unit
vector in the z-direction.
So that's a matter
of just notation.
Might as well use a
vector for k incident
because that is
really the vector
momentum that is coming in.
And it's sometimes useful to
have the flexibility, perhaps
some moment.
You don't necessarily
want the wave
to come in the z-direction.
There's another vector that
is kind of interesting.
You're observing the wave in
the direction of the vector
r, the direction of
the unit vector n.
So it's interesting
to call k an incident.
I think people write it with
just i, so ki for incident, k.
And then, well, we're
looking at the direction r.
So we call the
scattering momentum
or the scattered momentum, kn.
You're looking at that distance.
So might as well
call it that way.
So with these things,
we can rewrite
the top equation making
use of all the things
that we've learned.
And it's going to be an
important equation, psi of r
is equal to e to the iki dot r.
So we have to replace
the e to the ikz by this.
Then we have the
Green's function
that has to be integrated.
And you have to see,
we've decided already
to approximate the
Green's function.
So it's integral over r prime.
So the only term here that has
an r prime is this exponential.
So all of this can go out.
So the way I want to make it go
out, we will have the minus 1
over 4 pi here and the
integral d cubed r prime.
And I'm going to have the rest
of the Green's function placed
in the standard position
we've used for scattering.
So we're still redoing the
top integral, the G plus,
which includes some of G plus.
We've taken care of
all of this part.
And now we have
that other factor.
So it's e to the minus ikn.
I could call it
the scattering one.
But I will still not do that.
Then we have the u of r
prime and the psi of r prime.
So this is our
simplified expression
when we make use of the fact
that we're looking far enough
and the Green's
function has simplified.
So let's keep that
for a moment and try
to think how we could solve
this integral equation.
Now there's no
very simple methods
of solving them exactly.
You have to do
interesting things here.
It's fairly nontrivial.
But finding approximate
solutions of integral equations
is something that we can do.
And it's relatively simple.
So we will come back to
this because in a sense,
this is nice.
But you must feel that somehow
the story is not complete.
We want to know the
wave function far away.
This has the form of this
function that when we wrote psi
is equal to e to the ikz
plus f of theta phi e
to the ikr over r.
If we know this f
of theta phi, we
know everything
about the scattering.
But it almost looks like
this is f of theta and phi.
But we don't know psi.
So have we made any progress?
Well, the Born
approximation is the way
in which we see that
we could turn this
into something quite simple.
So let's do Born approximation.
So our first step is to
rewrite once more for us
this equation, psi
of r is equal to e
to the ikir plus
integral d q bar prime G
plus of r minus r prime u
of r prime psi of r prime.
OK.
We wrote it.
Good.
Now let's rewrite it
with instead of r,
putting an r prime here.
You'd say, why?
Well, bear with me a second.
Rewrite with r
replaced by r prime.
If we have an r
prime, replace it
with r double prime and so on.
So let's rewrite this.
So we have psi of r prime
is equal to e to the iki
r prime plus
integral of d cubed r
double prime G plus of r prime
minus r double prime u of r
double prime psi
of r double prime.
So I shifted.
Whenever I had an
r, put an r prime.
Whenever I had an r prime,
put an r double prime.
The reason we do this
is that technically, I
can now substitute this
quantity here into here
and see what I get.
And I get something
quite interesting.
I get the beginning
of an approximation
because I now get psi
of r is equal to e
to the ikir plus d cubed r prime
G plus of r minus r prime--
I'm still copying the first
equation-- u of r prime.
And here is where the
first change happens.
Instead of psi of
r prime, I'm going
to put this whole other thing.
So I'll write two terms.
The first is just having
here, e to the iki r prime.
The second, I'll write
this another line.
So integral d cubed
r prime G plus of r
minus r prime u of r prime.
And then the second term
would be another integral,
d cubed r double prime
G plus of r prime minus
r double prime u of r double
prime psi of r double prime.
So look at it and see
what has happened.
You have postponed the fact that
you had an integral equation
to a next term.
If I would drop
here this term, this
would not be an integral
equation anymore.
Psi is given to this
function that we know.
Green's function we know.
Potential we know.
Function we know.
It's a solution.
But the equation is
still not really solved.
We have this term here.
And now you could go
on with this procedure
and replace this psi
of r double prime.
You could replace it
by an e to the iki r
double prime plus
another integral d
r triple prime of G, like that.
And then here you would have
an e to the ik r double prime
and then more terms
and more terms.
So I can keep doing
this forever until I
have this integral, G
plus u incident wave.
And here I have G plus u
G plus u incident wave.
And then I will have G plus u,
G plus u, G plus u, incident
wave.
And it would go
on and on and on.
So this is called the
Born approximation
if you stop at some stage
and you ignore the last term.
So for example, we could ignore
this term, in which we still
have an unknown psi, and
say, OK, we take it this way.
And this would be the
first Born approximation.
You just go up to here.
The second Born
approximation would
be to include this term with psi
replaced by the incident wave.
The third Born approximation
would be the next term
that would come here.
So let me write the whole Born
approximation schematically,
whole Born approximation
schematically.
I could write three terms
explicitly or four terms
if you wish.
But I think the pattern
is more or less clear now.
What do you have?
Psi of r equal e
to the ikir plus--
and now it becomes schematic--
integral-- so I
put just integral--
G plus u e to the ikr.
Don't put labels or anything.
But that's the first integral.
And if you had to
put back the labels,
you would know how to put them.
You'd put an integral
over some variable.
Cannot be r because that's
where you're looking at.
So you do an r prime,
the G of r minus r prime,
the u at r prime, and
this function at r prime.
That's how this integral
would make sense.
The next term would be integral
G u of another integral of G u
e to the ikr.
That's the next term.
And the next term would be
just G u G u G u e to the ikr.
And it goes on forever.
That's the Born series.